let's say you own a pencil factory I'm a
worker in that pencil Factory
you can have all the machinery all you
can buy all the raw materials you want
but without me and presumably many
others like me to assemble the pencils
all you would have is a pile of wood
yellow paint graphite rubber and
aluminum okay that would be worth so and
that is worth less than the pencil when
you try and sell it and yet all of that
value added by labor apart from the
wages that you give me which if we're
being honest there is a major power
imbalance in our ability to negotiate
that well if all you if all that putting
the pencil together requires is basic
use of your prefrontal cortex then yes
your labor is alienable at lower rates
than if you are a doctor that's not the
fault of the person who owns the
machinery but if all but if the work but
if you didn't have workers like me and
your pencil factory and you are just one
man I do I have millions of people who
are willing to do that voluntarily
forming if you're just one person trying
to assess like assemble pencils you're
not gonna get very far you need workers
capital needs labor infinitely more than
labor needs capital that's why you have
worker cooperatives where the worker
fundamentally disagree on the
distinction between capital and labor
capital is just a term for money if
you're talking about money money does
not grow from the ground money only has
value because it was traded for labor at
one point or the products of labor so if
I take my money and I buy machinery I
have invested my labor in doing that
because I didn't get the money from
nowhere even if I got it from my parents
my parents didn't get the money from
nowhere the people who built the
machines required me to trade something
of value to them in order for me to
obtain the machines the people who
invented the machines required people to
pay them in order to get the patent to
that machine so they could build the
machine the the problem that I'm seeing
in what you're saying is you've still
failed if what you're talking about is a
system of volunteerism you still have
not named any area in which we disagree
and yet you're telling me that you're a
socialist and I'm a free-market er so
one of us got this wildly wrong and I'm
pretty sure it's not me
the differentiation I draw and I'm not
alone in this or not one person trying
to redefine anything the director
differential differentiation I and many
others like me draw between socialism
and capitalism is that under capitalism
when you as the owner of the factory you
give me a wage the wage could be 725 it
could be $15 could be whatever an hour
right right but you you give me a wage
all all the additional profit above the
made from selling the pencils or
whatever good you produce above what is
reinvested into the company ultimately
goes to you or the investors do it those
who own shares in the means production
right under socialism those people are
the workers and the example I give again
is cooperative enterprise no those are
the people who are investing the risk so
if they carry the risk then they get the
benefit the owner of the factory carries
the risk therefore he gets the benefit
the workers in the company you mentioned
if that company were to go bankrupt they
would carry the risk as well as the
benefit if the company goes bankrupt and
this guy has to pay off all of his debts
the worker may lose his job but he's not
the one who's going to incur the debt of
having gone bankrupt if you incur risk
then you are the one who pays the
downside the worker does not pay the
downside okay it is the investor who
pays the downside who invested in all
the machinery who sunk millions of
dollars into making your labor
productive because guess what your labor
is without that machinery dunk nothing
you don't have a pencil to put together
young tap to what you don't got the we
don't got the paint you'll got the
rubber you don't cut them out of got
nothing right you're sitting there
standing outside twiddling your thumbs
it required somebody to invest no who do
you think put more in they I've spent
millions of dollars buying all the
machinery leasing the place making sure
there was a management structure doing
the LLC formation making sure all the
tax code was in compliance or use
standing outside because you can stick a
piece of graphite into a piece of wood